retest by toxicity tests after working on detoxification for months, will they be back to normal?
Maybe, but, you know, again, okay. So my level of toxicity,
current level of toxic load is equal to my current level of toxicification, that's a word.
My current exposure to toxins might as my ability to get rid of them.
So if I'm doing a lot more on the side of detoxification, so I'm doing a lot more to support
detoxification pathways, refer you back to the seven phases of detoxification. If I'm doing a lot
of those seven detoxification to get rid of, you know, these poisons that I showed positive on a test,
shouldn't they, therefore, be, you know, lower after a period of time of doing that? Well, theoretically,
yes, in a perfect world. This problem is we're not living in a perfect world, we're living in a toxic
sewage dump. And it'd be that as likely as I possibly can. So if we're currently exposed to things,
then, you know, it's going to be very difficult to plead my body when I'm not,
when I, when I am, you know, currently exposed to stuff on a regular basis. The other thing is,
is like, oh, I'm cut down my exposure. I know I'm not exposed to this anymore. I don't, you know,
let's say it was glyphosate that was high. And now I've switched. I'm only eating organic. And I
retest my glyphosate levels after six months. And it's actually higher. What the heck, you know,
well, two things could be possible. Still can be exposed to glyphosates through cross contamination.
Or I could be actually dumping a lot more glyphosate. And it's just showing higher that you're a test.
Because if you're a test, it's going to show what is what I'm dumping at that time. So it could possibly
be elevated because I'm actually succeeding in detoxifying. But more likely is, is, is more
current exposure. So it depends on the toxin itself. Let's say I might go toxin came back higher
than I would say almost surely yours. There's some current exposure that you haven't addressed yet.
And you have to dig deeper to figure out where you're being exposed to this stuff. Or let's say if
it's glyphosate that's probably current exposure to. So, you know, let's say if it's, let's say it's a
heavy metal. So let's say you were elevated in mercury. And you did. And then you had mercury fillings
removed. It may take a while to get all that out of your system. So it depends on the toxin. You kind
of got to think through these things. But if your test showed elevation after a period of time,
it could be, current exposure could be you're just, you know, you did something to, to remove a
substance like mercury fillings. And now you have a lot of detoxing to do. And this kind of shows you
your progress that you still need to make. And so you got to kind of think through these things
depending on what the toxin is.